language learning starts with you with
the person with the learner who's
learning to me is almost like a model of
life itself what matters is what we do
and when we start something that's the
most important step to do something some
might be better than we hope for some
might be worse than we hope for but
throughout my life every time I have
undertaken to do something it has
brought me some of the greatest
opportunities in my life when I was I
think 19 working on a construction site
in Montreal I was fired with that
particular section of the job had been
completed so I went down to the dock in
Montreal in three days I asked to see
the captain of the various ships that
were docked in Montreal Port asked to
work my way across to Europe day three I
found work on a German freighter called
the garretta shell and here you see a
picture of me with my crew members uh
and I work my way across Europe